[Music]  a few years ago my partner alex and i  we realized that there was a huge issue  with the way cleaning products were  being sold  [Music]  the family could only be bought in  plastic bottles and once used these  cheap bottles would inevitably break and  end up in landfill  or worse in our oceans affecting our  seas and our wildlife  over 400 million of plastic spray  bottles solely from cleaning products  alone  will be thrown away every year in the uk  so in august 2019  we launched elm kind we're a plant-based  eco-friendly yet effective alternative  to home cleaning product  since launching we've so far saved over  10 000  plastic spray bottles from ending up in  landfill but as we're still seeing  haunting images of animals being washed  up with microplastics in their stomachs  it's clear that a lot more still needs  to be done  [Music]